listen ever since you put on that cape
and then dj announced you know black
adam people have been talking about this
you guys meeting and seeing youtube on
the carpet here is certainly not cooling
down those rumors about there being a
cinematic meeting of the muscles
oh man i don't know honestly it all of
that stuff is so above my pay grade i i
know nothing of the larger bigger
conversations and honestly i'm kind of
grateful because it's like i just get to
go to work do my job stoked to do my job
then it all gets cut together by you
know very talented people and we've made
a really cool movie and i'm just stoked
for that
so if anything happens beyond that
awesome but you know it was just it's
cool that you know we're all just trying
to promote a thing that we love you know
they're they're trying to promote their
black adam we're trying to promote our
shazam fury the gods and uh it's a it
was a heck of a day at hall age
now lucille and helen mirren they look
like the loveliest people ever but are
they quite intimidating when you're
staring down at them
no not at all i mean not that they're
not great actresses and like like
brought it they 100 did but you i mean
they're so lovely as people that it's
very difficult to be intimidated because
you know that they're just excellent and
they're so good at their job and i don't
know yeah buddy thank you so much